We've talked about a few
different things so
far like market segmentation and
personas.
And I know you're a startup, so
you just want to get to the bottom line.
So where do you start?
What do you do first?
Well, let's talk to an expert.
What does Moore have to say about this?
>> As a startup, I think it's best
to start with persona and I think
the persona is the target customer
with a compelling reason to buy.
And then I think as you start to
engage them with that persona.
And so you put out your app or
you put out your downloadable thing, and
you're hoping this
persona will download.
Your communication,
you use pictures that you hope
look like the person you want.
And you say things you
hope they want to hear.
And then you start seeing how
well they engage with you.
And sometimes as you watch them engage,
you realize, I have the wrong persona.
This thing is actually getting traction,
but
it's getting traction with
a different group of people.
So you say okay,
well now maybe that's my persona, right?
So you have to be willing to move.
I think when you start getting
quantitative around the discipline of
segmentation is when you want to scale.
When you start scaling and you start
saying, I'm going to actually make
significant marketing,
I'm going to raise capital somehow.
And I'm going to spend
that money on marketing.
Now you need to have a more
analytical approach to where
you're targeting that money.
But the beginning I think
it's much more qualitative.